salut c'est Lucas brut nature mettre des
pieuves des milliers de pieuves dans un
élevage pour la consommation humaine
c'est un projet qui pose beaucoup de
questions et dont je voulais vous parler
cette semaine dans la grande
explication cette histoire de ferme de
pieuvve j'y ai pas trop cru au début
j'avais du mal à voir comment on pouvait
passer de ça à quelque chose comme ça
mais une entreprise espagnole il
travaille depuis des années et on parle
comme d'une innovation responsable et
durable son projet pourrait concerner
jusqu'à 1 million de pieuv par an et il
a déjà déposé des demandes
d'autorisation este es nuestro miedo no
que el primer proyecto sirva de
referencia para que otros países o otras
compañías empz a poner Granjas de pulpos
pues en face plusieurs ONG et
scientifiques craent que ce projet soit
inadapté à cet animal qu'on a jamais
élevé à grande échelle j'ai donc voulu
creuser à quoi ressemblerait un élevage
géant de pieuvre quelle préoccupation
concrète ça suscite je vous
[Musique]
explique nous sommes sur les îles
Canaries plus précisément sur le port de
Las Palmas selon le Mia Canarias aura
c'est cette zone qui a été choisie pour
accueillir une ferme d'un nouveau genre
le projet s d'y élever et d'y abattre
des milliers de pieuvre pour la
consommation humaine bon déjà petit
point avant de commencer pieuvre ou
poupe j'ai appris qu'en français c'était
la même chose c'est les animaux de la
famille Octopus pour moi c'était surtout
des animaux mystérieux et assez
intelligents que j'avais pu étudier pour
plusieurs vidéos de brite nature alors
pourquoi vouloir faire de cet animal
sauvage un nouvel animal d'élevage à
grande échelle pour essayer d'y voir
plus clair j'ai étudié les arguments de
l'entreprise nu pescanova à l'origine du
projet j'ai aussi interviewé une
scientifique opposée au projet et une
scientifique qui travaille sur les
pieuves depuis plusieurs années j'aime
bien les comparer à des Chats Sauvages
un peu c'est très joueur ça a besoin de
pouvoir explorer ça a besoin de se
cacher avant toute chose j'ai voulu
savoir à quoi pouvait ressembler
concrètement cet élevage de
pieuvre alors oui en aquaculture il
existe déjà des élevages de poissons ou
de crevettes mais là il s'agirait de
l'espèce pieuvre commune et ce serait la
première fois qu'une pieuvre serait dans
un élevage de grande échelle derrière ce
projet il y a Nueva pescanova c'est une
multinationale espagnole de produits de
la mer qui revendique 12000 employés
dans le monde mial es la primera vez que
se va a cultivar a nivel industrial
principio 2023 estaríamos en condiciones
de empezar a
cultivar el proyecto tiene una capacidad
total máxima de unas 3000 toneladas per
esto no lo vamos a alcanzar el primer ao
journal britque Guardian explique que
cela signifierait abattre environ 1
million de pieuv par an la ferme
s'organiserait sur deux étages avec à
terme plus de 1000 bassins et 1000
bassins voici ce que ça représente de
manière extrêmement simplifiée certains
servirai à la reproduction des pieuvres
et d'autres à différentes étapes de leur
croissance la concentration des animaux
pourrait atteindre 10 à 15 pieuves par
mètre cube selon un rapport de l'ONG
Eurogroup for animal mais l'entreprise
dit que ce chiffre n'est pas encore fixé
Roberto Romero Perez le biologiste qui
supervise l'aquaculture pour
l'entreprise nueva pescova a indiqué au
Guardian nous ne savons pas encore
quelle densité nous pourrons atteindre
tout en reconnaissant l'objectif
d'augmenter la denité afin de la rendre
économiquement rentable resto de
paretru la
granante un premier point qui fait débat
c'est de savoir si ce type d'élevage
peut répondre au bien-être des
[Musique]
pieuvres cette pétition lancée en mars
2023 a reçu près d'un million de
signatures elle demande d'interdire
l'élevage de pieuvre avant même que la
première exploitation est ouverte au nom
du bien-être des pieuves mais quelles
sont les craintes concrètes un premier
défi à relever c'était de faire
reproduire des pieuvres en captivité sur
plusieurs générations les équipes de
recherche de noeva pescanova ont franchi
cette étape en 2019 une partie des
préoccupations pte sur les conditions
d'élevage de ces animaux qui ont des
besoins particuliers no son animales
sociales siempre están escondidos son
animales muy territoriales por lo tanto
creemos que en unas condiciones de una
Granja intensiva que sabemos que se
caracterizan por grandes densidades
ambientes estériles todo muy controlado
no concuerda con la naturaleza de este
animal por tanto creemos que eso va a
dar problemas de agresividad incluso de
canibalismo pescova biarine Center
laborato nueva pescova fait ses
recherches sur les pieuvres ici
l'entreprise affirme prêter attention à
l'eau à la lumière à la nourriture et à
d'autres facteurs pour répondre au
besoins des pie adaptando las
condiciones de cultivo y con una
alimentación completamente dirigida para
cada una de estas fases se aliviado el
estrés de estos animales de una manera
tremenda y Adem no hemos
encontrado
mais des on et des scientifiques se
demandent si ce sera toujours possible
dans un élevage à grand échelle nous
recherche PL qu' va mie éever de façon
individuelle o PES par en groupe dans
TER de consommation les il ycune
régulation sur comment les élever d'aut
cri vis notamment la méthode d'abattage
des pieuvres Roberto Romo confirm au
devra être abattu en utilisant des bains
d'eau froide et de glace descend
progressivement jusqu'à - 3 degr selon
lui c'est la forme de sacrifice la plus
respectueuse et la plus humaine que nous
connaissions aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout ce qu'on utilise dans la recherche
nous on a on va les anesthésier d'abord
pour bien saisir les enjeux il est
intéressant de se pencher sur les
spécificités de cet
animal la pieuve possède environ 200
ventouses réparti sur ces h bras qui le
rendent de nombreux services monde le
sait leur capacité de camouflage où ils
peuvent changer de couleur et même
d'apparence en espace de quelques
secondes ce que je savais pass c'est
qu'elle a un cerveau central mais aussi
huit mini cerveaux qui pilotent chacun
des bras cela lui permet d'être plus
rapide et d'avoir une certaine autonomie
dans chacun des bras pour sentir ou
saisir des objets pour un animal du
groupe des invertébrés qui n'ont pas
vraiment de squelette elle possède
d'importantes capacités cognitives il
peuvent résoudre des problèmes peuvent
notamment ouvrir un bocal si on met une
Poie dans un bocal ils vont réussir à
ouvrir ce bocal et ils vont apprendre à
le faire de plus en plus rapidement et
de la même manière ils peuvent apprendre
à attaquer certains objets pour pour
avoir une récompense si on compare à des
vertébrés est-ce sont plus intelligents
j'en suis pas sûr et c'est très
difficile de comparer l'intelligence d'
espèce à une autre par contre si on
compare un poupe à une boule ou une hîre
on a quand même une grande différence
cognitive et ce n'est pas tout en 2021
ce rapport de la London School of
Economics a trouvé des preuves très
solides de sensibilité chez les animaux
de la famille des pieuvres basé sur de
nombreuses études ce rapport suggère que
les pieuves sont sentiantes c'est-à-dire
grosso modo qu'elles peuvent ressentir
la douleur et la détresse il y a la
présence de cepteurs don des bras
d'écoues donc qui sont des récepteurs à
la douleur cette information elle peut
elle est actuellement traitée dans des
centres nerveux qui sont assez
similaires de ce qu'on observe che les
vertébrés qui sont des évidences que ces
espèces peuvent ressentir la douleur et
donc le stress en réaction en 2022 le
gouvernement du Royaume-Uni a reconnu
officiellement les pieuves comme espèce
sentiante dans cet article de 2019 s
scientifique écrivait déjà une des
implications de la compréhension de
l'intelligence des pieuvres devrait être
le refus de soumettre les pieuvres à une
production de masse mais alors pourquoi
pourquoi comme le fait l'entreprise
qualifier ce projet de responsable et
durable et pourquoi vouloir en faire un
élevage considor de Pulpo pero seguido
también de Portugal Italia Grecia son
los países mediterráneos de Europa pero
también hay otros países donde ya se
consume también Pulpo es por ejemplo en
Japón en Estados Unidos hay Mucha
demanda es un producto que se ha puesto
de moda en estados
unidosfique la pêche de pieuvre a
fortement augmenté dans le monde pour
répondre à la demande et depuis 10 ans
elle aussi entre 350000 et 500000 tonnes
par an de son côté l'Union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature classe le niveau de menace sur
la pieuve commune en préoccupation
mineure à l'échelle globale ça c'est le
niveau de menace le plus faible sur son
échelle et c'est notamment dû au fait
que contrairement à d'autres espèces la
pieuve commune est largement présente
dans les océans de la planète malgré ça
l'Organisation des Nations Unies pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture
considère que le niveau des pêchees
actuel sur les pieuves n'est pas durable
et qu'il faut donc s'attendre à une
diminution des approvisionnements
l'élevage de pieuvve se pose donc en en
alternative le PDG de Nueva pescanova
Inacio Gonzales explique que si un
élevage responsable et durable voit le
jour il contribuera à la conservation de
l'espèce et permettra aux nouvelles
générations d'en profiter mais pour les
scientifiques que j'ai interviewé il
n'est pas certain que ce type d'élevage
a un impact sur les quantité P
Pescadores no van a dejar de pescar
Pulpo porque haya una compañía que
produce Pulpo yo que se continuarán
haciendo las dos actividad par ailleurs
les pieuves sont des animaux carnivores
des élevages à grande échelle
nécessiteront forcément de grandes
quantités de nriture il faut un large
volume de proie pour nourrir les pou ça
c'est une première difficulté il faut
les adapter à la taille de l'animal donc
c'est quelque chose qui est compliqué
qui demande beaucoup de ressources au
final si
estultur anim car
queiment
que Don des sousproduit de poissons déjà
pêché et qu'elle s'efforce de remplacer
une partie des protéines animales par
des sources végétales l'entreprise
revendique déjà l'équivalent de 10000
terrains de football consacrés à
l'élevage d'espèces comme des crevettes
ou des turbos les pieuvres représentent
un nouveau marché potentiellement très
important mais alors dans quelles
conditions la consommation de pieuve
peut-elle être
durable noeva pescanova défend toujours
son projet comme une solution soutenable
en septembre 2023 le gouvernement des
îles Canaris a finalement décidé de
soumettre le projet à une analyse
environnementale plus poussée que ce
qu'elle avait prévu jusqu'à maintenant
selon le média Canaria auras cela
concerne généralement des projets qui
ont des effets importants sur
l'environnement si l'autorisation est
accordée il faudra encore plusieurs
années à l'entreprise de construction et
développement pour atteindre la
production espérée c'est-à-dire comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure 3000 tonnes
par an soit environ 1 million de pieuves
par an pour Flavie Bidel de nombreuses
conditions doivent être remplies pour
qu'un élevage respectueux des pieuvres
et de l'environnement soit envisageable
ce que j'ai vu dans un de leur articles
c'est qu'ils en sont à la 5e génération
qui ne ressemble plus du tout à un poup
sauvage ils le disent eux même ils ont
ils ont fait c'est une ste de sélection
naturelle où les les individus qu'ils
ont maintenant ne cherchent pas
forcément à s'échapper ce qui est contre
nature pour un poup ils admettent que le
comportement n'est pas celui des
comportements de la première génération
c'est pas à moi de dire est-ce que c'est
bien de faire l'élevage intensif ou pas
despèces senent je veux dire que c'est
pareil dans ce cas-là pour les Pors les
vaches les les poussins ce qui
m'inquiète ça reste de rester dans le
bien-être des animaux on sait que ce
sont des animaux qui ressentent la
douleur et donc effectivement il est
important de les respecter Elena Lara
elle demande la fin des projets
d'élevage dejar de introducir especies
carnívoras en la acuicultura y a lo
mejor basarnos más en especies
herbívoras o en organismos filtradores
como los vibalvos o cultivar algas lo
que tendríamos que hacer es ajustar
nuestro nivel de consumo un poco a la
sostenibilidad no de las poblaciones y
de los recursos naturales que tenemos o
sea que queramos comer Pulpo todos los
días de la semana todos los fines
semana mon
éise de vous partager des points de vue
sourcés et les informations qui m'ont
marqué sur cette question et tout
simplement d'essayer de comprendre dans
quelle mesure c'est possible de passer
d'un animal sauvage un animal de ferme
et les conséquences que ça peut
avoir j'espère que ce nouvel épisode de
la grande explication vous aura appris
des choses et intéressé bien sûr on ne
peut pas tout dire en une dizaine de
minutes voici un petit bonus sur un
autre aspect que j'ai découvert en
laboratoire quand je travaillais ave
bimaculoï j' avais un trou audessus de
leur aquarium et je je faisais passer
des poies pour regarder le comportement
prédateur et souvent quand je leur
mettais leur pro pas préféré celle qui
qui était la moins préférée de leur
proie si je mettais des crevettes
généralement il préè des crabes il va
jeter de l'eau et ENF une propulsion
d'eau vers le trou où je libère la proie
comme pour exprimer un mécontentement
aprs ce sont des choses qu'on perçoit
quand on travaille avec eux mais oui on
a vraiment l'impression qu'ils
ressentent et qu'il communiquent leur
émotions à leur certaine manière
certaines personnes disent que le
camouflage fait partie d'une façon de de
communiquer leur émotion est-ce que
c'est vrai ou pas c'est difficile à
montrer si vous connaissez bien ce thème
n'hésitez pas à apporter des compléments
en commentaire ou vous pouvez aussi
poser les questions qui vous resteraient
après l'épisode comme d'habitude vous
pouvez liker la vidéo pour que plus de
personnes découvrent ce sujet on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
sur les animaux ou l'environnement et je
vous dis à
bientôt